hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
once in a while a perfect game appears
usually they are triple-a titles with
more content than an average human being
can fathom with jaw-dropping
photorealistic textures and stellar
voice acting
well steamworld dig to is here and it
has none of the above attributes but
it's so good it deserves to be
celebrated call it a review or a salute
to greatness but here are 6 things we
absolutely love about the brilliant
steamworld dig - and before I forget
we're also giving away a few game codes
at the end of the video so stick around
to enter let's set the scene in an
alternative world where the populace has
embraced technology creating mechanical
robots for many Charles fast forward a
few years and steampunk and Wild West
culture have taken over the world
giving us the steam world series without
giving too much away it's a world filled
with cave-dwelling humans mechanical
steampunk cowboys mysterious hidden
technology and digging so much borrowing
in fact that Dig Dug would be impressed
[Music]
you play as Dorothy not ask is finding
the main character from the original
game and uncover the reasons behind the
constant earthquakes in the area don't
worry if you've never played a
steamworld game before this was my first
venture into the franchise and I had no
problems with any aspect of the game
thanks to the simple but effective
gameplay loop mine for resources sell
them upgrade your character ok I know
that doesn't sound very interesting but
I assure you it is there's an intrinsic
addictive element to the exploration as
you literally carve out your group to
the next objective picking up precious
materials to sell them the next time you
resurface
everything can be lost in an instant as
death during the early stages wipes out
most of your backpack full of goodies
similarly with the light that you carry
will you decide to continue descending
or will you resurface to get more fuel
for that torch as you'd expect from a
game of this type every aspect of your
character is upgradable need a bigger
bag for all the valuables you find it's
here how about the torch that lasts
longer yes is here too if you've got the
cash you can upgrade Dorothy on top of
the basic gameplay loop are the
additional items you'll uncover for
example the jackhammer fists allows
Dottie to break previously
indestructible rock changing your entire
approach to dungeons even revisiting old
caves which you once thought were
complete to now unlock new areas in only
a few hours you'll have access to a
projectile cannon and the greatest hook
shot I've seen since Link to the Past on
the snez there's more new abilities and
upgrades than that but I don't want to
spoil those as they are gain changes and
continually revitalize the game's
mechanics steamworld dig to is littered
with hidden areas to find and artifact
and upgrade items to scour the world for
but it's the caves which are a genius
break from the gameplay loop we talked
about each cave offers a handcrafted
puzzle with different skills being
tested some require platforming
abilities whereas others test your
planning and timing although none would
really difficult the sheer volume of the
caves and hidden areas were astounding
for example in one cave I had to
initiate a rock fall before getting out
of the way as quickly as possible in
another an enemies tracking bullets kept
me on my toes the variety and variation
is a joy to behold
the ps4 version of steamworld dig tool
is a great experience but the Vita
version is in a league of its own when
you buy steam welding 2 you will receive
both versions it's a cross by title
I found playing on the Vita ideal for
those downtime moment we all get whether
that's on the commute to school or work
while sat in a waiting room or even when
you're waiting for someone to get the
heck off the living room TV the game
plays perfectly on the Vita as you'd
expect and whether it's a five-minute
pastime or a two-hour session the Vita
is the perfect home for steamworld dig
too sadly there is only one negative
from the whole experience and it's the
lack of cross save between ps4 and Vita
so if you're grabbing this one you'll
have to pick a platform or have two
separate games on the go by the way the
reason why most of the footage you are
seeing is from the early stages of the
game is due to my preference of playing
on the Vita version which sadly I can't
capture with many games in the
metroidvania genre once the story is
complete usually there is no need to
continue playing
but steamworld dig to offers a new game
mode after completion to unlock it you
must be one of those completionist
people gathering all the fascinating and
strange artifacts which are taken to a
local vendor as I write this I am only
32% through the game secrets so at
present I haven't sampled the endgame
content but as soon as I finish here I
am getting straight back to it if you'd
like to enter our giveaway for a
steamworld dig to code please follow the
game's creators on Twitter image and
forum games I'll link them in the
description below next write something
funny in the comments and about the ones
you like I'll randomly pick a winner
tomorrow it will be any view code so
make sure you have a compatible PSN
account
steamworld dig to is 20 dollars or 20
euros in the US and Europe and 15 pounds
here in the UK if this is not the type
of game you usually go for I completely
understand
I felt the same but I'm so glad I tried
it and although it is primarily a ps4
title this so far is my Vita game of the
year it may have a few shortcomings by
the lack of cross Dave but that's really
a frustration and it's not the end of
the world anyway I'm going straight back
into the mines to unlock more secrets
and hopefully that end game content I
imagine from PlayStation granade it's
been a pleasure I see
you